pour lille ou 15 ans pas question de
consacrer tout son temps à ses copines
ou à sa famille l'adolescente est
bénévole au secours populaire depuis
trois ans je suis très fier de faire ça
et ça m'apporte du bonheur ça me fait
plaisir en fait de donner de mon temps
et mon énergie
j'ai déjà aidé bon plusieurs collectes
alimentaires et puis loeb 2 j'ai
organisé une collecte de jouets dans mon
lycée il n'y a donc pas d'âge pour
donner de son temps aux autres
le secours populaire souhaite que chaque
bénévole trouve son intérêt dans les
différentes actions qu'ils proposent
entre les collectes de jouets de
vêtements l'émission père noël ou encore
l'accompagnement des petits en vacances
moi ma tâche moi c'est faire les
accompagnements des enfants dans les
familles d'accueil mais je fais ça de
gare en gare gare parisienne gare de
province et ensuite trois semaines après
je vais aller rechercher
on l'a ramené à leur part ont fait
beaucoup de choses et c'est beaucoup de
choses diversifié c'est surtout ce qui
est intéressant c'est parce que on fait
pas toujours la même chose le secours
populaire des yvelines et compte ainsi
1800 bénévoles répartis dans 25
structures pour seulement quatre
salariés une petite armée de bonne
volonté
au fond c'est quoi c'est consacrer du
temps aux autres était sous ses abords
me dire que je me lève le matin et que
ça sert à quelque chose
le secours populaire des yvelines compte
sur cette année anniversaire pour
recueillir des idées fraîches auprès de
ses bénévoles
plusieurs congrès seront organisées tout
au long de l'année afin de renouveler la
gouvernance de l'association et
réfléchir à l'avenir